ciao ragazzi bentornati allora puntata
ciao ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata iniziamo subito
l'allenamento voi non conoscete sapete
quanto sono una persona che ci tiene
assolutamente un'alimentazione sana e
corretta che cosa ha detto ok hai detto
sudore ecco perché ho deciso di fare una
ricetta per tutti quanti gli amanti
dello sport come me che si possa far
male
ecco perché ho deciso di fare delle
barrette proteiche per tutti quante le
persone che ci tengono al fisico
[Applauso]
ma andiamo avanti esistono vari tipi di
barrette proteiche al mondo oggi ne
faremo una veramente seria al cioccolato
120 grammi di proteine al cacao 160 g di
fiocchi d'avena 70 kg di mio fratello
gabriele 80 g di burro di pino o burro
d'arachidi a secondaria di voi volete
usare e latera rena a quanto basta
chievo 40 80 grammi vabbè mi farò capire
che cosa faremo ci troviamo all'interno
degli studios di casa mia con gabriele
scilla uno stuntman e una fitness
personali che che apre ci troviamo anche
una personale dover uscire
allora è bene senti un po perché è così
importante la presenza dell'importo di
glutine
durante un allenamento grazie mille per
la domanda guglielmo è fondamentale per
integrare e curare la propria massa
magra
prendiamoci cura dei nostri muscoli
comunque dovreste dovesse vocina magari
mi metto io accetterò sta favorendo
sbagliare gabriele dov'è che mi metto su
di salinagrande sei tornata metti tutto
io sono stanco magnetica di chi ce l'ha
se i bicchieri chi vuole birra che la
regione è pazzo per un primo né passato
né 10 del mattino
iniziamo con procedimento per prima cosa
abbiamo 120 g di accusano dormito
pochissimo per guardare il tutto è
diventato di nuovo risveglio la notte mi
sento le musichette in testa tocca tutte
musichette continuano e certamente non
ti curar di me 120 vuoi che vada così
ma c'è una cosa sui tic toc minute aso
che mettono sempre la lingua dei denti
perché secondo me passa ex troverò ti
mettiamo proteine di cioccolatini come
conosco le proteine queste proteine
hanno un buonissimo e ammettiamo e
predire che stai alzate libro talenti
per soli le proteine ragazzi sono
fondamentali nella
di noi esseri umani perché create
ricette spostare le polveri e la testa
va facendo hanno avanzato oggi dopo il
salto finisce questo discorso
il saluto allora perché sono importanti
le proteine mettiamo 160 g di fiocchi
d'avena appieno solo produzione gli
occhi di gatto prendessi tic toc quindi
dovrei fare tutto con una notte magari
quanto del mattino ostacoli così
l'europa wow perché permangono la mia
tutte le top
giriamo queste sembrano le ricette di
distruggere culinaria quello che uno può
un campo che ci siete qua dentro
a parte gli scherzi spiego cosa conclude
in excel un intrigo mischio aggiungiamo
scusate è giusto
no vero non sono nostra vai per me
metti che ha 80 g di burro d'arachidi lo
vedi qua basta tarare lì e non solo
tarato bassa parare tari taro e
credibile come tu in ogni cucina sia il
successo non solo il tempo ma metti
questo cambiamento ha aperto un po di
diarrea di culto che schifo di myair da
papà così non frega dalle 7 del mattino
così
questo ci hanno preso successo sotto al
palco poi siccome ha fatta teheran
potevo raccogliere in bustine un'opera
tipo passato era testa dovuto fermato
passa numerosa è passato a questo punto
aggiunge un pochino di laterina che ami
aggiungere la signorina fi tipo 40
millilitri perché sto facendo come dire
che questo è già fatto verrà preparato
torino e lattine sono lamentati che
simula della preparati o famiglie perché
la poppata è poi bottini 40 ho guardato
da 40 ma a patto che paghiamo se poi
trattenere la bella e aiutate di melania
stiamo seguendo la ricetta di edoardo
baldini lo vedo che vi lasciamo qua
sotto e lui va un pochino occhio solo
per questo poi puoi mettere come faccio
a fare metà di questo occhio sta un po
di più
nel dubbio abbonda quando la seta vino
al latte molto proteico pochissimi
carboidrati in molte proteine le mette
già diputerà guarda che è squadra che la
fazione che fa guarda ne esce la tac a
cui è poi aiutato un'azione diventata
rughe ninja questo è mangiata da casa
tetti purtroppo le banche credo che dopo
questa prima bomba proteggano in mano
adesso qualsiasi cosa si maturano a
bomba al burro d'arachidi buonissimo
grassissimo grassi buoni ma grassissimo
lega perché è giusto reintegrare con le
proteine guglielmo domanda da un milione
di dover che tu quando ti alleni
distrugge il muscolo e con le proteine
lo aiuti a ricomporsi e questa è
l'integrazione ma tenuti nei non ci
stanno soltanto per integrare curdo
quando sta bene ci sono le proteine che
il posto allenamento ma in generale
durante una giornata è bene assumere che
il giusto numero di proteine la maggior
parte di noi non assume il giusto
apporto proteico ed è un male perché noi
dobbiamo prenderci
guardate le cozze in cucina aspetta che
fa molti top o poi fatevi sette camere
da letto
da qui la mappa sì ma non ho capito tu
cosa fai
prima di venire da te faccio vedere
questo bensì anche lui dormitina mattina
testa adesso potrebbero restare no
l'abbiamo vista abbiamo praticamente
finito è la ricetta più facile e veloce
del creato gioco quando già pagati
adattamento non vorrei meglio piano i
ragazzi vi chiedo scusa pensavo che
fosse così io qua qua a tutto il gruppo
liu.bo proponimenti attivi anche
manipolarla d'annunzio mio firmo che
cosa loro far diventare deve sembrare
mostro che la giusta consistenza questo
è il camera il rilevatore di loro una
consistenza in h deliziosa è un po
essere appiccicoso
pizza di torino
[Risate]
[Applauso]
marmo giallo tempi io famoso e mi chiedi
di provarci ancora
risponderò casi un po spessi neste
barrette che ne dici allora le barrette
solitamente non sui 70 grammi individuo
folla da 60 un po pignolo serve cioè
questo club e cammina sul cruscotto io
sono il pignolo pignolo e pignolo
prendiamo la carta fuori in india ma lui
è stata una mano io allora ragazzi ho
creato il mio panetto c'è troppo
silenzio in questa stanza a questo punto
30 minuti in freezer gas
ti prego ci ho messo sette ore
autorizzate così faccio vedè che soffre
un attimo prendono le redini della
situazione
ok google timer 30 minuti vai 31 numeri
dispari meglio primo è sempre google
scusami ma se così è il passo economica
stai parlando con diffusione
dell'ambiente
male pure tappare un buco vaymer al 29
minuti 25 minuti
ma allora che facciamo in questo tempo
faccio qui accetto un punto che c'è
tutto un po bandito permettiamo sul mio
tracolli facciamo ti toccano tracciano
un bel pupone e senza totti armi lati
che ha mai capito come funziona scorso
prima con un movimento di alleggeriscono
basta che tengo tutto da dom e dei
bambinelli adesso prova con le gambe
scusi vita non certo in modo da farlo
una lezione rivisitata penso con la
testa nel termosifone però ecco i cicli
gonnelline troupe uno struzzo atn ce
l'hai
pesaro 8 sul bacino 123
la cultura tattica satinato bravissimo e
lo stesso piano la palla grandissimo
davide ok non l'hanno mai fatto sica
perché non è fattibile
siamo destinazioni libri così way back
down butti giù le gambe richiamato il
parlamento a quello lì è morto ti prego
vieni capri è passata un'ora e mezza in
freezer per palestra di cattolica
scusate ragazzi hanno avuto la china
vanke questo il nostro forse una carta
da forno su una forse guillermo levati
sposta chi è affetto così invitante
ragazza che bello rega io muoio sforna
ma ciò deve solo uscire
andiamo fare un assaggio ragazzi ma
prima di farlo iscrivetevi a questo
canale metteteci per i monaci e
commentate questo video con
l'esposizione mediatica
siamo arrivati al momento all'assaggio
bagarre a un pestaggio e canino pensava
che io
veniamo li paga
[Musica]
io no
siccome mi vede spesso chiesto qualche
consiglio su che prodotto utilizzare
questo è un esempio di uno dei bacini
chiarle un musetto e la germania che a
me non piace fan di via martini e posso
dire una cosa ha cambiato un mesetto
chief acquisita da noi con una salsetta
posizione mediaticamente questo video
grazie gabriele per aver rovinato ogni
stimolo istante però noi ci vediamo
martedì prossimo con un ologramma
tormentata con le forbici commentate con
esposizione mediatica social media o
commentare una esposizione mediatica se
siete di gabriele o commentate con ne
mangerà un altro pezzo bel propone come
tanto il pupone pupone o commentate con
un bel pupone se siete del mio team ma
ci vediamo martedì
ciao